make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
all right what's going on guys this is
rob and i wanted to wait
until the beginning of this week to make
this video right because i didn't want
to really spoil anything for anybody
with falcon in the winter soldier that's
the reason why i made that poll
here on my channel to find out when it
is that you guys watch and uh by and
large it looks like most of you guys
watch it on friday
it trickles off to saturday and then
basically drops off on sunday right so
by monday
pretty much everybody has seen the
newest episode of falcon in the winter
soldier right or enough people
that anybody who complains about
spoilers is because they just chose not
to watch the show right or whatever
reason right but
uh the fact remains i wanted to make a
video explaining isaiah bradley but
here's the biggest issue that you have
with this right and not really an issue
um there's not a whole lot to explain
here right i mean there's nothing that
we can't explain in the span of like
five to ten minutes so we're gonna kind
of beef this up a little bit
right and we're going to provide a
little more meat and potatoes to this
discussion and kind of give you this
full well-rounded depiction
of how isaiah bradley fits into the
super soldier serum the weapons plus
project how it all kind of leads to like
wolverine and different things along
those lines
so isaiah bradley first appeared in
truth red white and black number one in
january of 2003 and he was created by
robert morales and kyle baker now the
writing for the story is fantastic
the art is kind of wonky like it's a
little
it's a little outside of my wheelhouse
if i'm being honest with you guys
but it doesn't really detract from the
story which is the important thing now
the overall gist of this and this is the
segment where i kind of talk about how
there's not
a ton for us to cover i mean i guess
there is and we can cover the actual
story if you guys want like if you guys
are interested in seeing the actual
story we can make videos on it right i'm
moving back to colorado here in the next
few weeks we can just use it as filler
content while i'm gone and just throw
out the origin of isaiah bradley in
comic book form so let me know down in
the comments if you guys are interested
in that
but um either that or i was thinking
about remastering uh the legend of blue
marvel adam beshear
and just kind of doing that right
because now that isaiah bradley's in the
marvel cinematic universe i feel like
it's only a matter of time before we get
adam brashear right that guy is a
powerhouse man
but uh nonetheless so the idea behind
this is that isaiah bradley was
effectively the second person to kind of
become captain america but not
officially so the idea behind this is
that
uh in in 1940 steve rogers was still
alive and well and in fact
even when isaiah bradley was operating
as captain america
steve rogers was still alive right he
was he was still there and
he wasn't really frozen in ice yet uh
the whole the whole notion behind this
is that as you guys know
steve rogers became captain america and
then abraham erskine died and the super
soldier could never
truly be duplicated what you also had
was a guy by the name of dr
[ __ ] who basically lived in uh in
germany or operated in germany and so
the germans were creating their own
version of the super soldier formula
that'll become important here in a
minute but the reason why this matters
is because in an effort
to create more captain americas the u.s
military basically went through and
performed a series of experiments
but you couldn't necessarily do that in
the public eye i mean by that point you
still had the immigration act of 1924
also known as the johnson reed act which
wasn't really eliminated until 1965
and there were things like just kind of
sidetracked from the comics for a second
when you had guys like laughlin and guys
who advocated eugenics that was actually
a thing that happened in the united
states the us was practicing eugenics
before
before the germans were during world war
ii like you would literally have people
who get off the boats if they were
deemed to be undesirable based on
a previously created series of
guidelines by the u.s government they
would be sterilized right so like the
united states
did a lot of eugenics like they would do
in the appalachians like they would go
to the appalachian mountains and they
would ask
people like would you take a shot if it
was good for you and they were like yeah
so they would like sterilize them
because they were deemed to be
undesirable people they didn't really
want to have
you know basically at least as the us
government referred to it polluting the
gene pool
and so because that was the mindset at
the time the other part of that was
the the birth of the super soldier
project like we can create more super
soldiers outside of steve rogers and so
what ended up happening
is 300 black americans or really 300
black soldiers were basically whisked
away to a secret base in mississippi
and then experiments were performed in
trying to create a new super soldier
that was essentially
just like captain america the funny
thing about this is that isaiah is the
closest the united states has ever
actually gotten and really even anybody
in the world has gotten
to actually recreating steve rogers it
cannot be done right the perfect super
soldier uh formula that steve rogers has
cannot be duplicated right but you can
get insanely close
and basically isaiah is one of those
guys now the whole idea behind this is
that the experiments were insanely
gruesome right so like they would inject
these guys with a serum and there was
one guy about 18 minutes after he got it
his body exploded but there were only a
handful who actually survived and that
isaiah was one of the guys who survived
and then didn't really have any kind of
like
physical defects in terms of how he
looked and so what you ended up having
was the us government
turning this particular group which was
basically covered in the black vine
concept they turn them into a black ops
team right they would literally go
through and just perform these missions
that like
nobody in the us military outside of a
handful of highly ranked individuals
would really know about
now all this came to a head when word
had reached the ears of the military
that [ __ ] was in germany trying to
create a new super soldier formula and
they had this particular camp where it
was being done
and so where the the story kind of
unfolded with pretty much everybody
inside of isaiah bradley's team
except for isaiah being killed because
of the fact that he had
really looked at captain america and
almost idolized him because at that
point in time the the fictional captain
america comics had been produced in
marvel comics that this basically led to
isaiah basically idolizing steve rogers
and so what he did is he actually
stole uh a captain america uniform and
then
took off to germany to face off against
the the you know
possible super soldier serum to
basically conduct his mission ultimately
he was successful but he was essentially
believed to have been killed in action
by the military now
at that point in time his wife faith had
believed he'd been killed right the way
this worked is that when these soldiers
were snatched up by the military that
letters were sent out to every single
member of their family saying they died
in an explosion right and that's why the
remains can't really be recovered or
that's why the remains are charred or
whatever kind of cover story they wanted
to use
and so with isaiah having been believed
to have been dead uh that kind of wraps
things up for that story except for the
the captain america aspect of it right
so the way this played out
is you initially had the guy who was
kind of running this whole program and
then you had his assistant
his assistant who was named private a
private merit was eventually busted on
drug charges
but uh but in his his property and all
the stuff that he owned his warehouse
was a tattered captain america uniform
the one that had been used by isaiah
bradley and steve rogers had been
notified about it and so steve rogers
basically started tracking down this
whole thing and that's where it all kind
of comes and comes to a head right
that's where you basically learn
the whole story of isaiah bradley
because steve rogers is trying to track
him down
and then from there like isaiah doesn't
really have
i mean he's part of the crew in marvel
but not really in a in a massive way
right that focused more on josiah and
then it focused on
elijah right like basically the the son
and grandson
of uh of isaiah bradley if you can call
it that so the whole idea behind josiah
the son
of isaiah bradley is that he was a guy
who was who was essentially carried by a
surrogate mother right so
the super soldier serums effect because
it was not really a perfected super
soldier serum the effect it had on
isaiah bradley is that it basically
sterilized it right so we couldn't
actually have any kids they had a
daughter between him and his wife faith
and that was it
and so what ended up happening is a us
military basically took the eggs of uh
of faith and took the basically the
sperm of
isaiah and then used it on a series of
different women in order to carry a baby
to term and they went through like 30
different women
until finally one was born and so this
kid basically became known as josiah
right now josiah eventually visited back
you know went back to go visit his
family
and then vanished but following that
what you go into is you go into uh
elijah now elijah is a far more
interesting character he was part of
the young avengers the way this played
out is that the actual biological
daughter of
faith and uh and isaiah a girl by the
name of sarah she actually ended up
getting remarried she basically had a
son
but her son knew the story of the legend
of the black captain america in the
sense that
isaiah bradley's reputation began to
kind of grow and expand in the black
community right so it was like one of
these things where the black community
knew and believed that he was actually
the black captain america but nobody
outside of that really knew it right and
that was just kind of a way for marvel
to sort of explain his existence without
anybody like wolverine who's been around
for
a few hundred years knowing you know not
knowing that he doesn't exist
having characters like having a
character can kind of tie in strongly to
the black community so like when he
shows up to the wedding of like storm
and black panther then like a lot of the
black superheroes who were there the
prominent ones know exactly who isaiah
bradley is but nobody else does right so
it was a cool way it was a really really
cool
concept to kind of pull it off that way
but the important thing is that sarah
basically gets remarried she has a son
elijah
elijah lies about having the super
soldier serum right he lies about you
know having powers and all that kind of
stuff in order to get onto the young
avengers and so the way this plays out
is that eventually
he's injured captain america goes to
give him a blood transfusion and then
it turns out that isaiah had already
done it and so because of the blood
transfusion the super soldier serum of
isaiah
is passed on to uh to elijah and that's
how elijah becomes
the super soldier that's most likely
what's gonna happen in the marvel
cinematic universe it'll be like the
dying action you know the dying act of
uh of like isaiah
and falcon of the winter soldier is that
somehow or another his son will be will
be injured and then he'll have to give
him a blood transfusion and then
probably end up dying in the process or
something along those lines who knows i
have no idea well they'll find a way to
write him out but that's basically the
meat and potatoes behind
the whole notion of of isaiah now let's
kind of expand this out a little bit
right let's let's let's expand this out
so in the greater pantheon of the super
soldier serum and all that kind of stuff
how does isaiah
fit into all of this so as most of you
guys know we've talked about this before
right so if you guys are if you guys are
familiar with this kind of bear with me
while we run over this for the fans who
are people who are new so the way this
works is you have
project rebirth this is called weapon
one that's the actual
name for the kind of behind the scenes
secret name for it the reason why it's
called weapon one is because it's part
of the weapons plus
program and the weapons plus program was
a precursor to project wide awake the
project wide awake was the full-on
military and really even governmental
action of trying to contain and control
the mutant threat
weapon one or project rebirth was the
attempt to create a super soldier that
could actually
carry out that mission instead of having
to rely on conventional weapons and cops
and different things
along those lines again all that stuff
is stuff that we learned in grant
morrison's new x-men
those of you guys who never read grant
morrison's new x-men vote would tell me
that i was wrong so the the thing about
this
is that you go forward with essentially
abraham erskine the creator of the super
soldier serum dying and now can't be
duplicated there's no there's no way to
recreate the super soldiers here now you
would probably ask yourself why don't
they just extract a sample of captain
america's blood and then just synthesize
it from there well
two things one because steve rogers
probably wouldn't let them and two
it's what makes captain america unique
marvel would have no desire to do that
right i mean and if that if that was the
case it would be like giving everybody
you know spider-man's powers right or
giving everybody an iron man suit which
they've actually done before
are giving everybody the ability to
wield thor's hammer which they've also
done before or turning everybody into
the incredible hulk which they've also
done before
okay so so yeah you guys are right it's
entirely possible they could do that and
there really is any reason to believe
that they that they won't uh because
i've done stuff like that before
but the important thing here to kind of
get back on track the important thing
here is with abraham erskine having been
killed
that if you had weapon one which was
captain america
then you had weapon two which was the
attempt by weapons plus to create more
super soldiers after the perceived death
of captain america when he was basically
frozen in ice then isaiah bradley fits
somewhere in between one and two you can
call him one and a half
if you want to but he fits somewhere in
between one and two he's not really a
weapons plus
project it's really more of just like a
private government project where they
did it on their own and didn't really
have any involvement from weapons plus
but that's the whole basis behind this
right that's the reason why isaiah
is a little unique here is because he's
basically the government's attempt to
recreate the super soldier formula
but not necessarily under the purview of
weapons plus and then eventually project
wide awake instead it's just kind of off
the books away from everything else
let's see if we can make it work and
then if we can
then we'll give it to all the other
super soldiers who are out there right
we'll give it to everybody out there but
ultimately it all just kind of went
belly up uh the the whole thing you know
with isaiah
having believed to have been killed the
project was scratched you know and then
you just kind of went forward
into weapons plus and weapon two right
it's really kind of how that unfolds so
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end
if you are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoy this video make sure you drop a
like
and i will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you